[Music]
hi there i'm lucia subari technical lead
for google cloud cortex framework and
today i'd like to deep dive into the
technical details of our cortex data
foundation for sap
from previous videos you know that
google cloud cortex framework delivers
not just the reference architecture to
solve business problems but we also
deliver solution content templates and
deployment accelerators
we provide not just the recipe but we
also include the ingredients and some
pro tips to make your meal as tasty as
possible
let's first take a look at the
ingredients for the cortex data
foundation for sap
we start with raw table data from an sap
cc or s4hana system
we want to land the data into bigquery
and we want to make sure the data is
both consistent and updated as
frequently as our business requires
the records keep changing as updates
deletes and inserts flow into bigquery
this means we need an automated way to
process these records that are
constantly changing such as scripts to
process change data capture or cdc for
short
finally we need to make sure our users
can make sense of the current data
answer business questions and improve
decisions with insights powered by
machine learning
we also want to give users the
flexibility to consume insights with
their preferred reporting tool of choice
an application or even a spreadsheet
so how does google cloud cortex
framework help you put these ingredients
together let's take a deeper look
we want to keep the integrations options
open so any tool that gets the data into
the same structure with the same field
names as in the original sap tables work
if you follow an elt pattern as it's
preferable with bigquery you need a way
to distinguish which is the latest
replicated record for reporting purposes
this is accomplished by loading each
record with a timestamp and an operation
flag
once the raw data records are in
bigquery you have two options to process
the data leveraging the provided cdc
processing scripts
the first one you can generate views to
scan the raw table and pick the latest
record in real time
this is useful when you're replicating
data in near real time from a tool like
our bigquery connector for sap slt and
the business wants updates reflected as
they have
the second option is to use scheduled
jobs in cloud composer to merge or
absert the new or updated record in a
table in a specific frequency in batch
this is a good option to keep costs
under control when the business does not
plan on querying the data in real time
some replication tools have embedded
change data capture processing
capability and merge records directly
when inserting them
in these cases you can skip the cdc
processing in bigquery but we supply the
scripts just in case
now that we have processed our
replicated data and have the latest
changes in bigquery it's time to create
some models
our cortex data foundation has more than
60 pre-built views that anyone can
deploy and adjust to their needs
and the list of modeling objects
available will continue to grow as we
release new content
you will find the current list of views
and the tables they reference in the
entity relationship diagram in the
github repository link below
these views not only incorporate sap
specific business modeling but they also
tackle common but technically hard
challenges to solve such as unit of
measure and currency conversions
and the ability to deploy ecc and s4
models separately of consolidated into a
single view
we will also find scripts to process
data in batches flatten hierarchies and
consume and store data from other
sources such as weather or search trends
through directed acyclic graphs
these scripts are ready to be executed
by cloud composer within a schedule you
can customize according to your business
needs
everything you need to know about the
deployment of our cortex data foundation
is documented in our open source github
repository
you will find the key starting point is
the cloud build file that executes all
of the steps from optionally providing
test data
through generating change data capture
scripts to updates tables with the
latest results to creating the views
that provide the business logics
after you have cloned your repository
you can customize parameters to match
your business needs and available data
sources
and once your cloud build deployment is
complete you will see the data sets you
use test parameters have been populated
and you will find scripts to process
changes and retrieve additional data in
the bucket you have provisioned
these models are foundation to more
advanced solutions for example on the
google cloud marketplace you will find
our cortex application layer content
with sample applications for
synchronously exposing data through rest
apis or integrating with other
applications through pub sub
now that you know what cortex data
foundation is about check out the git
repository link here to deploy the data
foundation solution content you will
find all the step-by-step instructions
there
and this is just the beginning subscribe
to this channel and stay tuned to learn
more about advanced business solutions
and other exacting options like our
microservices-based cortex application
layer
[Music]